[Musique]
c'est une reconversion réussie pour
élisette maot après plusieurs années de
salariat elle a choisi de devenir
agricultrice et de travailler au côté de
son mari ça fait ben ça fait moins 2 ans
qu'on a commencé j'étais salariée
j'étais secrétaire médical du jour au
lendemain j'ai tout plaqué et ça fait au
moins 2 ans ben on on s'est mis comme
mon mari lui il avait intérêt agricole
ben du coup ben j'ai commencé à à faire
un petit peu à commencé à faire des
fleurs coupées j'ai ramené sur le marché
et du coup j'ai vu que bon ben j'avais
un peu de rendement de des fleurs et
puis ben on s'est lancé dedans
l'exploitation familiale repose sur deux
activités principales la première la
production de fruits et légumes la
seconde est la production de fleurs il
s'agit là de l'activité préféré
d'éisette
maillot j'adore les fleurs donc c'est ça
qui me qui qui me qui m'active quoi qui
me passionne les fleurs ben du coup à la
base ça veut pas grand-chose mais après
bon ben j'avais d'autres je me suis mis
avec il y avait il y avait des des amis
et qui connaissent dans l'art floral ben
j'ai appris des cours les cours de la
florale B après petit peu à petit peu
ben je me suis lancer dedans quoi
Monsieur et Madame maillot ont pris le
parti de cultiver des produits rares
qu'ils sont les seuls à proposer sur les
marchés on peut trouver des bananes
carrées des variétés de piments
surprenantes et autres légumes
longtemps bah surtout bon ben comment on
voir que le marché il il y a beaucoup de
choses que les gens ils ont pas et moi
j'ai l'expérience et je trouve et ben on
en profite de faire ce que ce qu'on
trouve ce qui R on fait toujours on
essaie de faire je me suis dit comme que
sur le marché il y avait plein de avait
d'autres variété ben on s'est mis des
variétés qu'il a pas sur le marché for
Elisabeth maillot participe
régulièrement au marché pays mise en
place par le Conseil départemental un
marché des producteurs où elle aime
particulièrement
exposer j'aime le marché pays c'est par
rapport que là on retrouve
d'autes on ramène tout ce qu'on a et on
a des légumes qu' a pas sur le marché on
ramène et du coup après on retrou d'A
d'autres personnes que y a pas sur le
marché aujourd'hui nous fait du ban
carré piment un peu des fleurs fleur
coupéit un cactus les Anri pemousse
c'est bien c'est c'est important pour
nous au moins comme ça ben les gens il
VO se sent aujourd'hui épanouie par son
nveau métier et ne regrette pas d'avoir
eu le courage de tout quitter pour vivre
la vie telle qu'elle l'entendait étant
femme agricultrice je regrette rien là o
moi je suis libre je fais ce que je
[Musique]
veux